l'abolition de la peine de mort est
importante pourquoi c'est un principe
important pour la république pour la
france mais même d'un point de vue de de
la civilisation c'est un acquis de la
civilisation et je suis très fier que la
france les faits assez tôt même si on
peut estimer tard avec françois
mitterrand au début des années 1980 et
alors alors c'est vrai que raymond et
mathieu ils ont parlé aussi avec leur
coeur je pense aussi et c'est ça et
raymond aujourd'hui je pense que t'as
pas du tout chose une amie c'est un bon
jour je
persiste et signe d'abord débat c'est
est ce qu'il doit rester toute sa vie en
prison ça d'abord c'était oui ensuite tu
nous pose la question je pense que de
mémoire est ce qui est pour la peine de
mort moi je me dise droit dans les yeux
et la peine de mort je les dis pour les
enfants pour les tueurs d'enfants et les
violeurs d'enfants c'est quoi le
problème projet quand le mec a déjà fait
de la récidive une fois deux fois quand
le mec a déjà violé une femme deux
femmes trois femmes il va ressortir
c'est quoi le projet de lui qu'est ce
que c'est son projet de vie alors moi je
suis humain comme vous on sait ça me
plaît pas de faire de la barbarie sur da
barbarie s'est passé pas une idée moi je
gère j'ai parlé en tant que père je sais
pas si vous avez des enfants je me suis
mis en tant que père je me suis dit si
on fait ça ma fille ce mec là si la
justice à 100 n'occupe pas c'est moi qui
vais m'en occuper et je vais tuer ma vie
et je me dis qu'est ma vie et j'ai pas
envie ni qu'est ma vie j'aimerais bien
qu'ils aient des réponses j'aimerais
bien que les mecs milliards j'ai bien
dit j'aimerais que les mecs se sentent
responsables et qu'assumer s'ils se
disent pas quand je vais tuer une petite
fille de 6 ans peut-être que je vais
faire dix ans avec les remises de peine
non huit ans je suis dehors c'est ça que
je n'aime pas entendre c'est cette
france là je veux pas vous vous avez là
la france que vous voulez moi aussi j'ai
la france que je ne veux pas entendre ça
je parle avec mon coeur et ce soir je
persiste et je signe ces mecs là comme
nordahl le landais etc les du trou les
tous les autres qui ont tué des gens
comme ça fourniret etc n'ont rien à
faire avec moi au supermarché ya pas de
réinsertion possible d'oublier de radio
avec tout le respect que je vous dois
j'ai entendu et je crois justement que
j'ai bien compris que vous parliez avec
le coeur comme comme un père comme un
fils et tout le monde peut penser comme
ça quand on prend le point de vue quand
on s'identifie à une telle horreur on
peut s'aider à une volonté de vengeance
mais précisément je crois que le grand
acquis d'une démocratie la grande
avancée en terme de 6 lisa sion c'est de
faire la différence entre la justice et
la vengeance vous savez c'est une
vieille histoire elle est déjà dans la
tragédie grecque de eschyle au vème
siècle avant jésus-christ ou ce débat-là
cette opposition entre cette loi
archaïque
la loi du talion de la vengeance du
meurtre par le meurtre ou de la
réparation du meurtre paramètres elle
est posée et des la tragédie grecque
c'est pas hasard d'ailleurs que ce sont
les grecs qui ont inventé aussi la
démocratie on fait bien la distinction
et c'est un acquis de la civilisation je
pense que de le comprendre c'est vrai
que c'est les grecs tueur a retiré des
moteurs soit pourquoi c'est la justice
nicos il doit pas être la vengeance
parce que si vous réduisez la justice au
crime ou aux moyens qui ont fondé le
crime c'est-à-dire le meurtre eh bien
vous annulez y compris la force même de
la justice jean tangente en tant que
père que hommes on peut on est
bouleversé on est meurtris on a envie
nous mêmes de céder à cette volonté de
vengeance c'est humain mais je crois que
le principe de la société le principe
d'une société juste démocratique et
forte pas une société faible c'est
précisément de ne pas faire de la
justice la vengeance sur et ça je crois
que c'est un principe fondamental aussi
dur qu'il soit de l'accepter et se
distingue chez ce que vous avez dit
parce que ces deux débats différents
c'est la peine d'une mort d'une part et
d'autre part est ce que les gens doivent
sortir un jour de prison à l'arrêt du
tout le même comment se protège bien que
la peine de mort doit être resté aboli
interdite c'est le signe d'une grande à
recommencer puisque ça alors déjà
monsieur moi pardon je parle pas du tout
émotions je pas par des familles comme
vraiment je parle avec beaucoup de
raisons d'abord un il ya un français sur
deux qui est pour donc n'est pas
complètement voilà un accotement
aberrant 2 pardon moi j'ai pas une
raison de deux mois je ne parle pas que
l'émotion je vais plus loin créé bon
c'est pas pour les enfants je vois pas
pourquoi pardon raymond mais une fille
de six ans sa vie a moins de valeur
qu'une personne comme à 25 donc moi
c'est pas c'est pas là c'est pas la
raison c'est pas une question d'enfants
ou pas enfants la troisième chose aussi
c'est qu'encore une fois ce serait dans
des cas en général l'argument c'est il
faut éviter l'erreur judiciaire donc
encore une fois ce serait dans des cas
où définitivement on a sur toutes les
preuves qu'on est sûr et ça concernerait
quelques personnes mais bat pour un vol
d'épicerie mais lucas très bon quatrième
point monsieur moi je parle pas de
vengeance je dis pas que la justice
française s'était souvent vous céder ce
n'est pas une question de se venger
donné en russie une personne avant
janvier potentiellement mais on est en
prison pour la société
prison à vie c'est pas le sujet c'est
calme le
savez vous savez et vous savez peut-être
pas mais si on devait laisser les
personnes jusqu'à là jusqu'au bout de
leurs peines aujourd'hui il faudrait
quasiment une prison par arrondissement
dans paris voilà où on en est donc c'est
pas vrai et j'en ai plein des cas comme
ça c'est monsieur ne fera pas de
personne ne va au bout de la peine parce
qu'il se fait un petit peu gentil dans
la cantine ça c'est un autre débat c'est
toujours un autre des biscuits il est
vrai que monsieur laramée acception c
est monsieur jour l'efs et dissuasion
c'est très attention quand vous dites
prendra peut-être 25 ans de prison
croyez moi c'est pas la même chose mais
ça c'est déjà gagné aux tirs et avis
c'est même à terme j'aimerais juste de
l'apprendre mais montréal aura tué par
qu'ils font de la peine de mort avec la
prison à vie c'est pas du tout le même
sujet j'entends bien ce que vous dites
sur l'humanité et que c'est pas bien et
je suis et je partage avec vous il n'y a
pas de souci là-dessus moi je vous
demande de trouver des solutions sur la
récidive qu'est ce qu'on fait sur la
récidive quand un mec a déjà fait trois
fois des gestes comme ça à des gestes
odieux et qu'on leur met en prison et
qu'on sait qu'il va sortir à 55 ans à 57
ans comment on se pose la question est
simple comment on se protège d'abord je
crois d'abord là je pense c'est déjà
très difficile de répondre à votre
question je suis sensible comme vous à
cette édition moi je veux la récidive et
de la protection de la société c'est une
évidence et il est certain qu'il ya des
personnes qui après avoir commis des
crimes abominables et dont on sait
qu'ils sont dangereux n'ont pas vocation
à sortir de prison mais ça ne veut pas
dire que nous devons céder à ce grand
acquis de la france et d'une société
c'est un acquis de quoi la kids
l'abolition de la peine de mort la peine
de mort ne peut pas représenter la
justice que précisément ce que vous
cherchez à punir le meurtre le crime
abominable yves le meur veut mettre là
le crime le plus abominable
quand vous cherchez à punir cela vous ne
pouvez pas vous mettre sur le même plan
que de crimes que vous cherchez à
sanctionner c'est la raison pour
laquelle une grande société civilisée ne
peut pas accepter l'existence de la
peine de mort et je rappelle que le
combat contre la peine de mort pour
l'abolition de la peine de mort est un
combat qui est encore actuelle puisque
vous avez des grands pays comme les
états unis où la peine de mort dont
certains états des états unis est encore
activement